if you know anything about today's
biographics episode you might know that
courtney love is a name that's going to
pop up eventually and her saga
is one of thousands of stories that
could eventually appear on my new true
crime podcast
the casual criminalist that's right even
more content from me the fact boy i now
have a long-form weekly podcast covering
some of the darkest things that i could
find from the uk doctor as the world's
worst serial killer to
the time an american socialite murdered
her best friend with her car
allegedly and totally got away with it
and much more but it's also
more laid back bit more free form with
the occasional laugh because
isn't death hilarious weekly shows
wherever you get your podcasts there are
links below now let's grunge it up
the 1980s were spent exhausted a decade
of shoulder pads leg warmers hedonistic
hair metal
and glitzy synth pop underneath the
surface a new generation was coming of
age
raging to be heard to find a voice that
voice arrived
coarse and barely intelligible screaming
over a simple riff of four power chords
that voice came from the burning pit of
the stomach of the harbinger
of grunge the reluctant figurehead of
generation x
this is the story of the pain and the
misery but also
the talent and the ambition of kurt
cobain
kirkebane was born on the 20th of
february 1967 in hoquim washington
in the northwest corner of the united
states when he was six months old his
parents donald and wendy
moved to aberdeen three years later the
trio became a four piece with the
addition
of daughter kimberly kurt was a fun and
precocious child delighting his extended
family
especially his more musical relatives
uncle chuck and aunt mary
it was mary who later gave curt his
first guitar lesson and introduced him
to the beatles and the monkeys but kurt
was also hyperactive and difficult to
control his parents were advised to give
him ritalin which
only made things worse he was then put
on sedatives before
an enlightened doctor advised to remove
sugar
from kurt's diet and that seemed to
stabilize him
unfortunately an unsettling event was
around the corner sometime after kurt's
eighth birthday mum and dad
divorced and life would never be the
same again around this time kurt
scrawled on his bedroom wall
what may have been his first piece of
poetry dad hates mum
mum hates dad it simply makes you want
to be so
sad the pain for his parents divorce was
made worse by
a sense of shame and guilt deriving from
his father's disapproval
don was disappointed by kurt's lack of
interest for sports and
seemed to object to him even being
left-handed
kurtz became withdrawn after the divorce
and erupted in sudden fits of rage
kurt argued constantly with his mother's
new boyfriend whom
he described as a mean wife-beater wendy
could not tolerate this behavior and
eventually shipped kurt over to don now
living in nearby
montesano their curtained on slowly
mended their relationship but just when
they were settling into a new happy
routine
don remarried in february of 1978. kerr
was not happy
not at all he disrespected his
mother-in-law bullied his younger
step-siblings and eventually took to
skipping school
to curb kurt's simmering rage and
aggressive streak don persuaded the
pre-teen to join the school wrestling
team
surprisingly he accepted even more
surprisingly he was very good at it
except when he lost on purpose just of a
straight dawn
their rift grew wider at the same time
kurt developed a fascination with hard
rock and
early metal bands like led zeppelin
black sabbath and kiss
he was becoming unrulia by the day and
don struggled to cope from 1978 to 1980
kurt ended up being carted off to a
series of relatives moving
at least twice a year in 2008
psychotherapist giuseppe troisi analyzed
koben's childhood by applying dr stephen
porges's polyvagal
theory according to this theory the
repeated trauma of neglect and
abandonment prevents the natural
absorption
into one's psyche of relationships
images and memories as a result these
will later erupt chaotically
in the form of intrusive images sounds
movements and sensations which are
impossible to control it's an
interesting theory which may explain
kurt's later musical style a stall which
was just beginning to emerge
at the age of 13 kurt moved in with his
uncle chuck a rock and roll musician the
two got on famously and it was chuck who
gave kurt his first electric guitar one
of chuck's band mates taught him to play
back in black by ac dc a pivotal moment
in his musical career
later on i found out about power chords
with power chords
you could play just about anything kerr
moved once again
back to don's his musical taste now
shifted towards punk and new wave
genres more attuned to his alternating
apathy disillusion
and outright anger dawn forced kurt to
join the school's baseball team which he
accepted only so that he could hang out
with an older kid
matt luckin a member of a local band
called the melvins
the band would later be hailed as one of
the trailblazers of grunge the subgenre
of alternative rock which
developed out of the washington state
scene the distinctive sound originated
around the mid-1980s with bands like the
melvin's green river and
mother love bone their style could be
traced back to non-seattle acts like the
pixies sonic youth
husker dew and the meat puppets or even
further away in time and space to the
gloomiest
noisiest edges of british post punk
nirvana later popularized grunge the
wider world alongside pearl jam
soundgarden
alice in chains and mud honey among
others but back in montesano in the
early 1980s the word grunge only meant
grime and nirvana was just a state of
beautitude transcending
suffering
kurt found a mentor in the melvin's
front man buzz osborne who
expanded kurt's musical horizons to
california hardcore punk acts especially
black flag in the summer of 1984 ker
began to take his guitar playing more
seriously but he needed a new amplifier
the right occasion came after he moved
back to wendy's in aberdeen
who had just remarried one pat o'connor
it was another unhappy marriage due to
his drinking
and womanizing one day wendy could not
take it any longer she took a gun from
pat's collection and threatened to shoot
him
but she didn't know how to load the gun
so she punished him in another way
she collected pat's entire arsenal and
dumped it into the wishcar river
kerr later recovered the weapons took
them downtown and sold them for a nice
sum
with the cash from the sale he bought
the amp that he needed the guy who sold
it to him spent all the cash he had just
made on pot which
he and curt then smoked together at the
age of 17 curt's use of alcohol and
drugs was relatively tame he had to be
careful with what he put into his body
due to several chronic ailments
scoliosis which
dogged him with back pain as well as
recurring bronchitis but worst of all a
constant
burning pain prodded him from the pit of
his stomach causing digestive problems
and frequent vomiting this was a gastric
condition that was never fully
identified and which as we'll see later
will become an integral part of kurt's
identity as an artist
on the bright side kurt's new amp was
powerful beast
windows and walls trembled when kirk
plugged in his guitar to
crank out his power cords when the
melvins moved to aberdeen kurt was ready
to audition for the band or
so he thought he proudly prepared one of
his own compositions for buzz and
friends but
on the day of the audition he just froze
kurt may have missed the chance to join
one of his favorite bands but he was
determined to become someone in music
the next obstacle in this course to
greatness were his parents
after a row with wendy kerr was sent
packing again to stay at dons
don accepted on the condition that he
gave up music surprisingly kurt accepted
not only that he pawned off his guitar
and what's even more surprising is he
took and passed an entry test for the
u.s navy when a navy recruiter showed up
to talk ker
returned to form he retreated to the
basement and rolled the fattest joins
he'd ever seen
the next day kurt left don's house never
to return
after he was cut off by his parents curt
led a vagabond's life for several months
the young rocker spent his days at the
aberdeen public library reading and
writing
at night sometimes he slept under the
north aberdeen bridge when he was lucky
he could use the van of a new friend
that he had met at melbourne's
rehearsals a
seven foot californian of croatian
origin chris novoselets
in between he would rehearse his songs
with his newly formed power trio with
dale crover from the melbournes on base
and greg horkinson on drums
under the name fecal matter the trio
recorded a demo tape at aunt mary's
house which
proudly gave to chris he wanted to
convince the croatian giant to play with
him
but for the time being the only activity
they shared was vandalism at night kurt
chris and buzz osborne covered the walls
of aberdeen with huge graffiti on one
occasion kurt was arrested and searched
the police found in his pockets the tape
of the band called millions of dead cops
which
they must have loved while performing
his vandalistic antics kurt picked up
addiction after addiction from acid to
godin and
finally heroin in the meantime kurt and
chris had finally joined forces
musically speaking
the two friends finally settled on a
name for their band nirvana with that
name they set out to record a demo tape
with local producer
jack endino kerr financed the session by
selling laughing gas he had
pilfered from a dental clinic where he
worked as a janitor kurt on guitars and
vocals chris
on bass and a returning dale crover on
drums recorded
seven songs six originals and love buzz
a
pop rock song by dutch band shocking
blue in january of 1988 kroger left the
band to concentrate on the melvins
handing the drumsticks to chad channing
throughout the rest of the year the pow
trio got noticed both thanks to their
energetic shows
and because of their demo tape
unbeknownst to the band endino had sent
the tape to one bruce pavett he was the
head of subpop a seattle label
which had already published
soundgarden's first ep habit loved their
sound and asked nirvana if they wanted
to release lovebuzz as a single with
subpop
the next step was to release a full
album pavo was happy to press and
distribute it but he would not pay for
the recording
luckily kurt had just recruited a second
guitarist jason everman the new guy did
not play one single note in the album
but he did something more important
he paid the 600 needed for the recording
sessions bleach never became a best
seller but
subpop booked a european tour for
nirvana which kicked off in october of
1989 in the uk
nirvana was the opening act for tad
another early grunjack from seattle it
was an important experience for curt and
friends but
also a borderline traumatic one the
bands played
36 shows in 42 days traveling across the
uk
and the continent in a crammed fiat van
experiencing equipment problems and
poor acoustics at every venue every
morning curt and town's frontman tad
doyle shared a peculiar right
doyle marred with gastrointestinal
problems had to throw up before getting
on the van and
cobain demanded the privilege to hold
the sick bowl kurt's own chronic stomach
pains worsened on tour
his journals published in 2002 offer a
vivid account of his daily
struggles every time i swallowed a piece
of food i would experience an
excruciating
burning nauseous pain in the upper part
of my stomach lining the pain
left me immobile doubled up on the
bathroom floor vomiting water and blood
cobain's relationship with his illness
may have informed his obsession with
everything visceral vomiting feces and
bodily functions
in general are occurring images in both
his lyrics and journal entries
and it clearly had an influence on his
singing and style
kurt later confirmed to his biographer
michael azerad that
both his screaming vocals and his
constant pain emanated from the same
spot
just below the breastbone in a new york
times interview cobain confirmed
i'm always in pain and that adds to the
anger in our music
i'm grateful to it in a way
[Music]
the tour continued from bad to worse
until nirvana and ted joined mud honey
for
london's lane first in december this was
anything but lame
audiences were treated to a rare sight
cobain enraged by his malfunctioning
guitar flung it in the air
another seller stepped forward holding
his base like a baseball bat and
he struck the guitar mid-air smashing it
into pieces this was not mere posturing
aping the who and jimi hendrix famous to
straws of instruments this was pure
motivated punk rage this was noticed by
the right people upon havana's return to
the u.s
when they played new york in early 1990
they attracted the attention of iggy pop
as well as the noise rock kings and
queens of new york
sonic youth sonic youth showed up with
their new buddy gary gershinto
gersch was an executive at gaffin
records a major music label that was on
the hunt for noise rockers and
cobain was looking for exactly that a
major label deal that could offer
nationwide distribution
curtin chris decided to start talks with
geffen while looking for a new drummer
chad channing had been forced out as his
compositions were being rejected for
being too prog rock or
elfin music as kurt once put it curtain
chris hick gold was the young drummer of
a punk band from washington dc
called scream kurt described him as the
drummer of our dreams and
we tend to agree as the new guy was one
dave grohl
groll had stepped in just at the right
moment when nirvana was about to make it
big besides gethin and
other major labels were interested sure
big companies loved their music but
they were also trying to ride the crest
of the wave a new era was dawning one of
raw guitars distorted bass lines
energetic drum roles and
introspective lyrics alternative was the
key word and every record executive was
on the prowl for the next
alternative sensation in the end it came
to two labels
gethin versus capital capital offered
one million
gethin a mere 287 thousand dollars but
kevin's offer
included an additional detail that
nirvana could not refuse
complete creative control the three
bandmates signed the geffen deal which
made kurt ecstatic
we have one of the best contracts any
band has ever had
we have complete control over what we do
if we handed in a 60-minute tape of us
defecating gevin would have to release
and promote it luckily havana's next
effort was not of that kind
the trio held up in van nuys california
with producer
butch vig and went on to record their
second album never mind they had made
bleach with 600 bucks
now their budget was 650
000 the new songs had the same raucous
desperate energy of bleach
enriched by cobain's knack for nailing
catchy tunes on the top of his distorted
power cords
or in his own words the bay city rollers
being molested
by black flag kurt chris dave and butch
were satisfied with the record when it
came out on august 27 1991. there was
one song in particular
which started with a clean guitar then
exploded into a roaring chord
progression
followed by an obstinate bass line nova
selects commented that the song was okay
he guessed and
later admitted that yeah it kind of
rocked the song became
a single on heavy rotation both on the
radio and on mtv
pulled by that single never mind went
gold at the end of september that song
was smells like teen spirit the anthem
that generation x had been waiting for
nirvana had arrived kurt had made it big
but would he be able to handle the
success
by december of 1991 nevermind had sold 3
million copies displacing michael
jackson's dangerous from the top of the
charts
the sudden fame did not sit well with
kurt from the outside he looked as if he
enjoyed playing the role of the rock
star but
close friends could tell that he hated
the sense of importance and
the scrutiny that came with stardom most
of all he could not deal with the mantle
received by the so-called generation x
the
role of spokesperson of messiah for a
whole
demographic that appeared directionless
and devoid of ideals and ambition
superficially cobain and nirvana seemed
to fit the bill some of kurt's lyrics
and journal entries expressed almost
proudly a resistance to taking action a
passive approach to life and the lack of
anything resembling a spine
superficially kurt did not lack the
ambition and the intelligence to get
where and what he wanted and we'll later
see how nirvana was more involved in
activism than many people might have
realized at the time
what the press and public seemed to
focus on were two aspects of cobain's
private life
his romance with courtney love and his
drug problems by march 1992
bam hits and rolling stone magazines all
insinuated that kurt
had been regularly using heroin kurt
denied at all claiming that his stomach
problems would not allow him to shoot
drugs but
this was not true according to
biographer michael azerad kurt had been
using heroin
since november of 1990. in part it
relieved kurt's stomach and back pain
most of all it helped him cope with
stressful situations
and the habits had escalated since then
to chris and dave's disapproval
azerath's claim also dispels the myth
that kurt was introduced to heroin
by his later wife courtney love it was
cobain who actually got courtney to try
heroin in 1991.
but let's proceed in chronological order
corny love was also a child of divorced
parents psychologist linda carroll and
writer hank harrison just like kurt she
had experienced a vagabond childhood
moving from
oregon to new zealand to england
courtney had considered an
acting career and even paid the bills by
working in strip clubs until she became
a professional musician
in march 1990 courtney formed the band
whole in september of 1991 their album
pretty on the inside was
released to great claim rivaling never
mind in the alternative rock charts
in between those two dates courtney and
kurt had been introduced by a friend
of dave grohls the initial flirtation
resulted in courtney presenting kurt
with a red
heart-shaped box which would later
appear in havana's album in utero but
during that period corny was dating
another old rock giant
billy corgan of the smashing pumpkins on
october 12 1991 courtney was visiting
corgan in chicago
when in his own words he flipped out and
made her leave his apartment nirvana
happened to be in town so courtney joins
them for an after concert party
according to corgan she gets completely
fed up goes home with kurt
kurt calls me the next morning and
begs me to let her come back to my house
that's the way it happened from then on
the couple proceeded at warp speed
shortly after kurt introduced courtney
to heroin she discovered she was
pregnant the mum-to-be decided to clean
up her axe although
she had used some heroin in the first
trimester of her pregnancy soon after
they announced their wedding scheduled
for the 24th of february 1992.
in june nirvana took off for a european
tour with courtney tagging along on the
23rd curt was rushed to hospital in
belfast
according to the tabloid press it was an
overdose actually kurt had gotten off
heroin replacing it with methadone
it is more likely that hospitalization
was due to a stomach ulcer or
methadone withdrawal the talk continued
until courtney suffered some
contractions during a gig in spain
it was a false alarm but her doctor
advised her to return to los angeles and
rest until her due date in the meantime
the media scrutiny had increased
courtney's band hold had also signed a
pretty sweet deal with geffen for a
million dollars
attracting the attention of vanity fair
the resulting interview with courtney
cemented with the public the image of
love and cobain
as two doomed lovers obsessed with
heroin and stardom
and unfit to raise a family when francis
bean cobain was born on august
18 1992 a los angeles family court
placed her
in the care of courtney's sister jaime
kurt and courtney were at their lowest
nirvana was also on the verge of
collapsing due to quarrels over kurt's
drug use and
the splitting of royalties but kurtz and
the band surprised everybody when they
showed up 10 days later
at the reading festival cobain was
brought on stage in a wheelchair
apparently drained of any energy but
he sprung up to his feet and gave a hell
of a performance and to think
that just days before kurt and courtney
were on the verge of suicide but the
thought
of winning back francis had kept them
from taking that final step
it seemed that kurt was getting his life
back on track
on september the 8th nirvana won two mtv
music video awards they then flew to
seattle
playing two shows and donating the
proceeds to support an anti-censorship
group and the legal battle against
oregon's anti-homosexual proposition 9.
all these contributed to clearing up the
image of curt and his band as
being just some wasted slackers in
december nirvana released their new
album insesticide a collection of
b-sides outtakes and covers
dedicated to kurt's musical heroes like
the vaselines and the raincoats
these successes were topped by kurt and
courtney regaining custody of francis
but bad news would be soon around the
corner
[Music]
it was time for nirvana to record a new
studio album initially titled verse
chorus verse
this would eventually become in utero
kurt feared that geffen would influence
the band into softening up their sound
so
he recruited producer steve albini who
had worked with the pixies and
heavy industrial rock band pig face the
album was completed in two weeks over
february of 1993
and it combined the two souls of nirvana
from the extreme punk aggression of
tourette's to the bittersweet melodic
riff of all apologies the album
would be released in september which
left nirvana some time for more activism
in april they played a benefit show in
san francisco raising funds to help rape
victims of
the conflict in ex-yugoslavia or cause
dear to
chris neversellets they then contributed
a song to the art of self-defense a
fundraising cd for the anti-violence
organization home alive
the album was released in memory of mia
zapata a seattle punk singer who had
been murdered on july the 7th
unfortunately the spring and summer of
1993 also saw the return
of kurt's old heroin habit on may the
2nd a delirious curt had
returned to his home in seattle from a
party he was back on heroin
and he was overdosing courtney tried to
revive him with a shot of buprenorphine
but nothing
seemed to work kurt was rushed to a
hospital and barely made it out alive
the following month the couple had a
violent altercation which prompted the
arrival of the police
courtney had found a stash of guns which
kurt had hidden at home
not the safest move with a
nine-month-old child crawling around
in july kurt experienced another
overdose in new york this time courtney
managed to revive him and cobain played
a concert that same night as if
nothing had happened the months before
and after the release of in utero
required havana to talk endlessly
on stage kurt went from strength to
strength nirvana had recruited
a second guitarist pat smear from the
germs allowing kurt to focus on his
vocal delivery he and the band appeared
to enjoy themselves when
nirvana recorded a live acoustic set for
mtv unplugged in october but offstage
cobain alternated brief episodes of
infectious happiness with
longer and longer periods in which he
just withdrew from the world around him
diving deep into a depressed state in
early 1994 nirvana was on tour in europe
when kurt's depressed mood decisively
took over his stage performance
two gigs in milan at the end of february
were just disastrous as
kurt looked dead on stage on march the
1st kurt walked off stage after a
concert in munich
physically exhausted and mentally
drained that would be his last concert
[Music]
on march 4th 1994 kurt was diagnosed
with bronchitis
and severe laryngitis he and courtney
flew to rome for treatment and
checked into a hotel the next morning
kurt did not wake up
courtney found him comatose having
overdosed on champagne and rehypnol this
was very likely
a first suicide attempt but kurt
recovered but five days later the
cabanese returned to the home in seattle
on the 18th curt was found by the police
locked in the bathroom armed with a
loaded gun and in a delirious state he
told the police that he was going to get
away from courtney but according to her
he was just going through another
suicidal episode one week later courtney
organized an intervention with family
and friends to
convince kurt to enter rehab in los
angeles courtney went ahead
checking in at the peninsula hotel in
l.a kurt reached california
only on the 30th staying at the exodus
treatment center for rehab
before leaving seattle he had bought a
shotgun from a friend
kurt did not stay long on april the 1st
kirk climbed the garden wall and flew
back to seattle the following day
he was spotted buying rifle shells in
the meantime courtney had heard about
her husband's escape
she put his credit cards on hold and
hired private detective tom grant to
find him
gronn went to investigate the cabanese
home but failed to check the greenhouse
over the garage that is where kurt
cobain's dead body was spotted by an
electrician on the morning
of april 8 1994. next to him police
found a cigar box filled with drug
paraphernalia
and a handwritten suicide note the
official cause of death was a
self-inflicted shotgun wound to the head
the autopsy revealed that the suicide
had occurred between april the 3rd
and april the 5th and what happened
during those hours remains a mystery to
this day
kurt had been spotted around seattle in
that time but the sightings
are not 100 confirmed there are other
mysterious circumstances around kurt's
death which have
prompted many to theorize that this was
a case of homicide
rather than suicide journalists ian
halperin and max wallace filmmaker nick
broomfield and
even private detective tom grant believe
that cobain was injected with a lethal
amount of heroin
before being shot by an unknown party
the most common theory is that courtney
love was behind cobain's death
kurt was planning to divorce her and due
to their prenuptial agreement
she would have inherited only half of
his wealth broomfield spoke to seattle
singer elden wayne hogue
known as el duce hoke claimed that
courtney had offered him fifty thousand
dollars to kill kurt but
he had declined the offer only for it to
be accepted by someone called allen
el duce was found dead eight days after
the interview
decapitated by a freight train the event
fanned the fire of conspiracy but the
coroner inquest and eyewitness accounts
ruled the death as accidental
ultimately suicide remains the official
and
more realistic cause of death bev cobain
kurt's cousin and a registered nurse
noted that kurt suffered from bipolar
disorder which can lead to suicidal
ideation
bev also pointed out that three of
kurt's relatives had killed themselves
a fourth one had shot himself in the
chest but survived the note found by
kurt's body was even analyzed by
forensic linguists eva sudyana
and neural fitry the letter was
addressed to kurt's childhood friend
bora and it expressed feelings of guilt
and frustration
not enjoying music or life in general
any longer i don't have the passion
anymore and so remember
it's better to burn out than to fade
away the forensic review
established that the note contained the
characteristic hallmarks of suicidal
intention
a lexical analysis further highlighted
the use of language typical
of genuine clinical depression so it's
likely that kurt cobain really did
believe that
it's better to burn out though many
still believe someone else
made that decision for him biographics
well not an appeals court so
we'll leave the final verdict to you the
viewers fortunately kurt's talent and
legacy
never risked disappearing into oblivion
nirvana only produced three studio
albums but his songs
and the group's beautiful grungy
influence are unlikely
to ever fade away so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below
don't forget to subscribe and thank you
for watching